what's really exciting time for you as
it's always I mean you've got season for
Game of Thrones shooting you've been
shooting in LA for Fast & Furious 7 and
also you've got your audiobook debut as
well which is very exciting with the
killing words by Lucy Christopher now
why don't you tell me a bit about that
novel and your character in it well
killing working is I guess you know kind
of the most obvious way to put it it's
almost like a murder mystery because we
have some girl that dies and then it
gets pinned on my character's father my
character Emily and because he basically
fits profile because he's my neck
symmetry man who has suffered from
post-traumatic stress and you know he's
been known to have blackouts and because
I learned post kind of his service in
the army so it's pinned on him and emily
is pretty much being told by every
single person around her including her
own mother that she should just accept
that and I suppose she knows something
doesn't quite fit and so you just kind
of the book is mostly about her dealing
with from her point of view so I'm hard
dealing with how her life has just been
turned upside down by this by this
tragedy and when they like to kind of
start to realize that actually maybe he
didn't do it because there are other
people who could have been implicated I
mean what was the appeal of the novel
for you the appeal yeah well I I think
it's that what kind of whodunit kind of
fingers you can I get led from a certain
street like the path and then you're
like wait hang on and set certain things
and jump out at you didn't go and that
doesn't quite fit maybe it's this guy
you know in that I think that's what I
like the most about it because I mean it
would all have been very interesting and
it just been I thought it was a crime
but I think it was much more exciting
figuring out who did it
so and it was great climax you do no one
even thought the guy that actually did
it say yeah great debut is definitely I
mean talking about making your audiobook
debut how did you find that oh it was so
fun and it wasn't it was a chance for me
because I hadn't done anything like
before and you know so it's so easy to
see what's going on when you're watching
the program or a film or whatever you
know you have any questions you have a
prop and straight away know what people
are saying and happily say me see
exactly what's going on but with an
audio book the only tour voice really
was a new challenge for sure how did you
find that challenge because as you say
you're moving from being seen on screens
you've got all your you know gestures
and facial movements idiosyncrasies that
you can use to purely sound isn't it
yeah I mean it was a huge challenge I
was a kind of times I I found it quite
difficult to notice to kind of make a
difference between certain characters
voices and you know and then but it's
just one of those things that while I
got into it and I kind of found my kind
of feat it was my family footing it was
a lot of fun and I really enjoyed it and
and the team that I would hear go I was
just so great and yeah I'm really I
really enjoyed working with them and
what's it like as well because I was he
is an actress he used to bouncing offer
that actors performances aren't you and
feeding into their performances too but
with something like this I guess you're
by yourself or just with a director or
somebody in a in a sound booth exactly
and they were right you know they were
really good at sort of let me know if I
lost the energy for this bit or no the
voice okay same as how before you know
so they were importing in that process
but definitely it is a completely new
thing just kind of carrying it by
yourself you know it's like an extremely
long monologue I guess but no one see
what you're doing it's just with your
voice say it and it was so it was so
challenging but in a good way
something I would love to do again I
think what I felt like I had achieved
something great once they'd finish
because I was Wow like that's something
that's not kind of easy to do you know I
mean I said I was sick please I mean you
a fan of audiobooks himself as well do
you know what everybody well I had them
growing up I mean when I was a child my
mum used to that was like our kind of in
right time for bed / knowledge a book on
and you know my favorite was them we had
two that we citizen - not me and my
sister cuz we share a room and there was
the ugly duckling and then the an was
and wardrobe is like I used to love that
like it was kind of making you
imagination and I think that's so good
about audiobooks so I am a fan of them
but I haven't read one and since one in
a long time and but they are actually it
kind of makes sense so she to me because
I travel so much now you know I'm always
kind of going somewhere and a lot of the
time I'm too tired to actually kind of
use my eyes and look at books they
actually sense to get one to record the
audio Toothaker I'm sure I mean if you
even from the world of the sound booth
to the world of the sound stage and the
kind of cast of warn you and the cast of
thousands in PA with friends what you
mean it's very exciting your first
season last season you must've been so
on top of the world you're part of it
cuz I know you a big fan as well and
such a dramatic season for Game of
Thrones - I mean how did you react when
you saw the red wedding for example when
I when I'm even when I'm ready at the
read-through and I could I I guess I am
was super shocked I couldn't believe it
because I mean I've read the book so I
knew it was coming but obviously to see
it in front of you is this completely
different day and even though I knew
coming
season I was speechless I couldn't I'd
the credits kind of just ran and I was
like speak and then my phone went crazy
because my friends were like why didn't
you warn me that we accident I think was
pretty universal when people were people
was kind of heartbreaking with the loss
of the stocks was astounding I you know
they were great characters and I was
pretty heartbreaking myself but it was
amazing
it was stunning wasn't it definitely I
mean if you're looking forward what do
you think you know that means for the
future of Westeros now oh who knows I
mean I'm just I think I'm just right
about Sant's of it oh yeah I like I like
that you know their family is completely
gone I have bran and Rickon and they
will get together again in the future
definitely team start back together
that'd be great wouldn't it thinking
about it we've lost so many people along
the way haven't we if you could bring
anybody back it's a life on the show
anyone who's been killed off in the
three seasons who would you like to see
back it has to be a stark really I think
mostly because I want to meet Shawn
being lazy because that parent was
potentially um he was a really good guy
and he was afraid you know
democratic guy and didn't wanted to do
the right thing and he was yeah I think
Ned Stark because he had he had he could
potentially have changed that the the
throne you know which I think at the
moment we kind of need because the
Lannisters aren't exactly doing a good
job of it say maybe you could give me
Sunday any advice for the seasons coming
if you could sit her down and say now
listen don't do this or do this what
would you say it's a tell if you seen
any kind of blonde green eyed beautiful
people walking around
to avoid them do that Brett my second
advice would be stick close to Denarius
because she knows what she's doing and
she seems to be um that like she seems
to be taking care of yes yeah definitely
good advice I mean over the over the
season so far what's been your most
memorable day of shooting I think most
memorable day its tween my first kind of
seemed like full scene I did where it
was the scene in season 3 where Daenerys
has come to look at the army and then
it's almost like the following day and
then we're negotiating the deal and it
was when we was kind of in us in the
slavers kind of room and I was
translating prisoners and then and then
Kings there is no is she was what he was
saying and not just from him I couldn't
do as an actress like it was my first
seat and we had this pretty big
challenge of translating meat of me
translating and then speaking Valyrian
the name valerian and it was a really
tough thing and myself and Dan
Hildebrand who played kraznys we spent
so much time making sure our translation
authentic so I'm of an evening we'd
really worked hard and I was kind of
learning parts of his Valyrian in order
to know what he said so and I could
translate it at the right time and you
know almost that thing is where we're
because translators are kind of are
listening and speaking at the same time
so to make it it worked like that and
make it look authentic not that I was
just saying a line then I was then
saying it and then you know translating
it so that for me was a good day and I
managed that the day finished and I was
so exhausted because I just had been
concentrating for like a really long
time and but it was just the best
feeling ever that we've done it and what
was really great it was it was directed
by a Dan Weiss and by DB Weiss and
David Benioff so to have worked with ot
and then to have them be like we are so
happy because you guys have clearly
worked so hard on or translation that we
you know they usually the veneering can
be quite difficult to cover and they
were like you guys just did it and so it
was all meant to TV you know like that
was a really great feeling and a feeling
of accomplishment so I think that's
probably my favorite just from from
joining the show and I think in terms of
the spectacle I think my favorite scene
was the plaza of pride seeing where
Daenerys hands over one of her dragons
and then we find out that she spoke
earlier in the whole time and it was
very cool about that is that everybody
kind of and we really hear here that
they kind of are only aware that she
speaks it because of Smith Sundays
reaction of she hears her speech see on
solid and she kind of like looks like
she's speaking valyrian and they can
adore everybody and then I love that
kind of look to kraznys right oh my god
he was so dads like so funny and and
then always he had the dragon saying on
fire very dramatic and we had him the
stuntman got set on fire just like kind
of a couple of thing from me and that
was very exciting and you know it was
great I think it was an exciting day
definitely sounds like it was amazing I
mean what's it you talking about the the
Dragons there and also the the valerian
I mean what's it like having how do you
approach kind of learning bags you say
you worked a lot with together to get
that translation feeling right but how
do you kind of learn the actual words
and do you kind of feel like you know
some of it a bit the end of the day I
mean had so much so I add lighting to it
because I am starting to look like how
to pick up on certain words but
obviously there are so many different
types of Valyrian within the show I mean
we have them fantastic dialect coaches
here who help us you know help us out
with with learning it but really what
I'm giving is is a series of mp3
recordings of David J Peterson who
creates the language the linguist just a
genius it's like amazing and he um he
said it as it should be said like we
asked and then he said it finically
syllable by syllable and we have it
written down also phonetically so we can
something like work out the sounds of
each thing and then it's just a matter
of repeating it until it until you know
that were there and then you can then
put it together and staple in me and it
is a process it taking it does take its
time it just you do take your time with
it really and believe that peace and
people tweet you and write you in
valyrian as well well you know there's
just certain sayings that people pick up
on from show like that that was a very
cool thing you know season 3 where it
says you know you die people sick to go
to war then send a sister alarm oh
goodness she goes yes you're not many
it's just one of those old power
payments a fan st. inventions and
Dragons as well what's it like working
with the CT cuz everything you've got
things like a stunt guy there who's
right next to you so it's on fire but
the dragons are all seated in on them
yeah well sometimes they have sort of
the stuff like these kind of the last
season he had like these stuffy things
like these I suppose they were like
models look like how it gonna look on
screen but they're obviously they don't
move and then so they're just for visual
effects and I haven't shot some with the
Dragons yet so I don't know in a half
this time but some rocks by the side our
green screen on you know so it's it's a
matter of using imagination and also
director or then in terms of timings
we'll go our dragonfly so we want to
look that dragon like you know so the
directors of the sea informs us of where
or what we're looking at and when they
kind of work what facility it's in and
say yeah do you still get excited when
you see the end product when you see
what what's what it's like and what it
was like on you know review acting there
in the moment and what it looks like on
the screen
oh it's instinct you kind of think you
know what it's a being and when you
watch actually you know idea it's just
so much magnificent than you could
possibly having mmm that time you know
it was so it's so cool yeah you know
just even the stuff that we had where we
were leaving and asked and she's got her
on e and that shot there was 8,000 you
know I'm solid warriors and then we were
all on horseback and then you see the
dragons and you kind of see the vastness
like we was in the middle of the Yser
desert which was incredible and you
could can't suppose you could kind of
picture it but it really wasn't on the
same scale as what they had they been
you know did I and did all the you know
made it looking amazing and you know it
was so to feed on I mean we should have
seen the other day and for the lack of
me I'd not work out how it was gonna all
be together and so I'm sometimes you
think that you kind of get an idea but
sometimes you have no idea so that for
me that when I watch that scene in
season 4 I think I'd be really
interested to see what it looks like
because it's really complicated and you
know our director was fantastic because
he he knew exactly what he was doing but
it was very hard for us to all kind of
picture it what was gonna happen it all
together so you know sometimes it's a
lot harder trip know what I was doing
what this is gonna be you know very it's
and beautiful and you know it's great to
hear you find it exciting still as we
all do as well as the audience that's
fantastic oh my god so excited because I
what show is a fan like I'm sorry
stupefying it's ridiculous
like you know yeah okay what's been
going on in thread of story line but
there's so much much more going on and
so I'm watching because I want to know
what you know I do
I do read everything detective really
come on
truly like um you don't really know I
feel like ever see until you watch it
the actors and their fantastic
performances and you know much you see
it all there you know it's so much fun
kind of powerful to me anyway so I
really look forward to watch everyone
else's stories and know what's happening
to my you know my favorite characters
you know they have you found shooting
this season compared to season
throughing because for example you're in
greater as time as opposed to Morocco
before weren't you it was in Morocco
last time um it's I mean it is hard we
do have work very very hard you have
very long days and you know it's very
warm we're very lucky to be in the warm
countries so that's right but I mean in
terms of the sets and stuff you know
we're not so much in it desert desert as
much so that you know we're not as we're
not gonna facing random sandstorms and
things like that as much yeah so that's
a nice but Morocco is such a beautiful
country I mean the people were really
friendly but then so operation people
well it's really I just feel like we're
really keen with the basis that we get
to get to shoot I mean I don't know in
terms of our story kind of still on on
route we're still on the road whistle
traveling and so I guess we have there
was quite a mother so far from life was
shot you know but obviously in terms of
missandei she's now been
for a certain amount of time so what I
feel that we get to know her a bit more
and that's really nice I mean kind of
last year she was kind of still very
much a product of her you know
environment and still very much a slave
in her mentality and I feel like this
year she's now been with Daenerys and
for a bit longer and she's kind of not I
mean she's an I think she's been good
she'll always be a certain like that's
what she's been conditioned to be her
entire life but I think now so she's
she's more comfortable to maybe show
have been like her personality a bit
more so that's really nice I think
hopefully the fans would enjoy watching
that I read on you and comedy you made
on Twitter and a little while back and
it was about a good friend of yours and
yourself and how you speak in northern
accents when you're excited which I
thought is fantastic so given that we've
got some great news attacks on the show
for example egrets with immortal line
you know nothing Jon Snow I thought
asking you to give me your best Ygritte
impression I know oh no oh no I can't
hang on you know nothing no virtual high
five
haha right I would love plays Ygritte I
think she's fantastic because when you
speak to me you're so kind of
well-spoken and very like you know so
not Ygritte at all Tesla to how a print
of inaccuracy is love it
you